hey everyone hey and welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
this is your host Tom cui if you are new
to the show you've stumbled upon this
through some related video or some
cunning SEO trickery this is a watchman
podcaster Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons
incredible graphic novel Watchmen we are
going through each issue in-depth
dissecting it discussing it celebrating
it and of course I'm not alone
as always definition is with me deaf oh
you doing how's it going everyone all
the fans out there we've been getting
pretty feedback this week so I feel like
yes celebrities now I feel like as human
diets right now getting the action
figure line ready we're gonna have a
pretty great time come on I said come on
you're right what you're saying because
I've done you know a few podcasts and
the moment when you sort of strike oil
is when you get your first email from a
listener and you know we're gonna well
yeah well just get into this so if you
want to get in touch with the show I
should say email us watching The
Watchmen pod at gmail.com if you listen
to those on YouTube it'll be on the
phone now if you just do it on podcast
but it'll be in the description and all
that but yeah we want to hear from you
you know let us know what you think of
the show what you think of an issue what
you think of points we've made or your
experiences Watchmen where did you first
read Watchmen etc and yeah that further
adue we've got this first email which
I'm excited to get into this with Eric
Ferguson so Eric thank you so much
forgetting to touch the show he says
first off cheers on the amazing podcast
I wish I could send you messages in real
time as I listen to your podcast there
is so much talk about of any Alan Moore
endeavor right now there's an amazing
documentary that finished about the
Vietnam War and so to hear you to
discuss it in such a detached way is
interesting as an American there is no
way to really get that here it's still
too controversial I was in the US Army
infantry and I have family who were
there in Vietnam myself I was in Iraq
during Desert Storm along with the
British 1st Armored Division of my ad
I'd probably have Alan Moore to thank
for not going over the deep end it's
also pretty interesting to see how Alan
Moore made use of fake news propaganda
to turn America against dr. Manhattan
that is exactly what's happening to
people here now America is turned
against them through similar techniques
the art and colors are amazing too I
attached some photos which he did attach
I should say thank you so much for
sending a merry they're really
interesting they showed many modes
of of Gibbons artwork across panels
amazing stuff
although Alan Moore was disgusted with
the movie and all the adaptions in
general you've got to give props to the
film director including the palette of
Norma in Ozymandias corporate office
practically Telegraph's Ozymandias
intentions in the palette was a piece of
ancient propaganda how the hell did he
manage to get hold of it it's priceless
the tablet is fought by some to depict
the unification of upper and lower egypt
under the king Narmer on one side the
king is depicted with the bulbs white
crown of upper southern egypt and the
other side depicts the king wearing the
level red crown of low and northern
Egypt Osman dies he's bringing together
the East and the West
you also joked about dressing up in
Vietnam garb [ __ ] me I have won but I
got it fair and square through some
marriage apparently truly amazing
country Vietnamese it's hard to watch
the comedian and act how he does in the
comic Alan Moore notes that Vietnam is
the 51st state must have obliterated the
population to allow them to enter the
union no ways a merit America allowing a
state of 50 million at that time Asians
he then concludes you should really look
at Moore's miracle man also in his
Marvel Man in the UK some of it is
literally a dry run for Watchmen the
same themes and techniques Alan Moore
really shows how writing Trump's
character and he takes lesser value
characters and writes a story more
amazed than anyone can do with more
famous characters finally it's weird to
hear Watchmen described as a graphic
novel for me it's a comic I collected it
monthly when it first came out I had to
wait a year to read and understand the
whole thing I'm glad that new
generations are encountering it it was
an instant classic back in the day and I
think it I think about our own dude my
comic collecting after reading it and
miracle man more and game and
deconstructing them so well thank you
for the podcasts look forward to
listening them all Eric yeah I guess
Eric Franke thankful for the email death
great to hear that right genuinely I
felt this and sense of pride here and
that that's made it worth doing all
these episodes for yeah great I tell you
what I'll put I've got a website me
self-definition core at UK you see few
centers the images that he's attached
I'll put them on the website yeah yeah I
know we'll look all the fans out there
kind of look but yeah really great email
like it must be strange having lived
through the conflict and then seen it
fictionalized
hmm I had like a weird surreal moment
where I sort of I know we were talking
about GF kala
time how that's transferred into fiction
almost and and the new Call of Duty game
right they've got a bit where where
you're just a sniper on top of the the
beaches of Normandy and you can see the
the boats come in and you've just got
shoot soldiers yeah as they run under
the landing of Normandy which it's weird
that that's now a form of entertainment
when people who lived through it would
have had to be like the most horrific
moment of their life probably it's weird
you know Watchmen kind of has certain
aspects of it that if he if he lived
through it in real life it would add so
much context to it mm-hmm
and probably really make it much better
comic to read yeah and I mean obviously
we're Zoar spoiled because we could just
read Watchmen as a collective addition
but it must have been crazy back in the
day to be like Eric reading it month by
month and trying to make sense of it all
yeah definitely
well I've sort of just lived through a
bit something like that myself because
the Dark Knight 3 the master race a
massive Dark Knight Returns fan Frank
Miller decided to release one of those
issues every three months so that was a
bit weird getting it delayed so I know
what Eric went through they're not what
not with the Vietnam right of course
yeah I got you know we're similar yeah
on comics at least so yeah again Eric
thank you and everyone listening please
get in touch and we had some comments as
well on the videos deficit right yeah so
we've got one from Archangel 630 who
says in relation to the issue with the
origin of dr. Manhattan he says I'm
pretty sure The Fatman crushing the
watch is actually a reference to the
atomic bomb dropped on Nagasaki maybe
it's a coincidence or he's telling us
that this event was the equivalent of
the second bomb for his life little boy
changed his life then fat man did it
again I don't know if it's on purpose
but there's also that beautiful parallel
where the Hashima bomb drops
he's also 16 which could be interpreted
as a reference to the bomb little boy
pS definition is great I really love
this issue and we've got one from Eric
Ferguson nothing I'm butchering that mmm
but great podcast people amazing how
productive a phone call can be yeah I'd
be happy a three-way a blue for the lads
nice observation on the cigarette styles
I think it's pretty clear that in this
world even in 1985 that the chronic
coffin smoker can accuse dr. Manhattan
of causing cancer that an Alan Moore's
world where Nixon is still president
there's a world where tobacco hasn't
been linked to cancer
yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah yes definition is
right there's a theme there's a fee mom
please please mention me in future
comments if you will so um yeah let's
get into this issue which I think you
said before your favorite issue of watch
man you know what ya think it did
nostalgic Lee you kinda remember this is
like whoa every panel in it mirrors the
the next panel and it's all the first
page might mirrors the last page and
it's all symmetry in the books called
fearful symmetry and I have did go but
this was probably the first issue that I
sort of read stuff online about mmm yeah
and that it see a lot of people
mirroring the same thought processes me
where they were like oh this is amazing
because everything mirrors and matches
it doesn't Liz probably there's probably
two or three pages that do but it's
still good obviously but you know it's I
think that dr. Manhattan issues better
yeah yeah yeah I I agree I agree I think
in terms of action in the storyline
obviously every single issue of Watchmen
is packed with narrative but it doesn't
quite push it for as much but as you say
everyone points to the mirroring in this
issue which is incredible you know it's
unbelievable light as an artistic medium
there's actually um if you just search
fearful symmetry analysis as an article
on medium.com that takes all the panels
that mirror each other actually puts
them next to each other so you can
really sort of appreciate and there's
certain things that I didn't notice as
well that they pointed out like there's
one where there's a window being crashed
through
and then the first time you said well
there's Rorschach jumping out the window
right at the end of the issue when he's
pursued by the cops and then you just
you see the window and you see Moloch's
voice saying like I heard a noise is
someone there and this is like 27 pages
it's it's a crazy fee isn't it of
structure yeah definitely and you know I
mentioned before I'm a website designer
and the difference between writing
something and visualizing it can softn
constraints to writing something and so
often you design a part of the website
you'll write all the code out and then
you'll put it live and you'd be like oh
[ __ ] that didn't look anything like how
I expected in the fact that Helen Moore
was able to describe each panel and have
it come to life in this way without you
know he didn't have the chance to go
back and revise it it's incredible that
he had this all planned out and it's
just such a feat yeah yeah it's it's
unbelievable it really is the execution
is flawless and when you look at the the
front cover as ever there freighted with
so many different meanings and you know
arguably watchmen as a whole but this
issue especially it's the idea of
reflection of things mirroring each
other and I just love that we have the
sign but the signs is made up of you
know a mirror and the sign is not only
made of a mirror it's a reflection in a
puddle and the raindrops are making
these small concentric circles and then
you also have the newspaper at the top
which is not upside down you can see
that the forecast is is on your side so
again it's his up and down sort of
dialectic thing it's crazy yeah and yeah
for people who aren't too familiar with
it you basically got a skull and
crossbones and sign with two R's above
it but one of these yours is backwards
and and it's just perfectly mirrors and
reflects itself at the sign and it very
subtly hints exactly how this issues
gonna work on the first panel so there
the first R is reflected in the last R
in it works so it could almost be viewed
as a book open just in its layout and
this reflects the the issue itself which
is a book that reflects it forever
within itself so it's a constant thing
it's very difficult to describe it is
one panel is drawn the same as another
panel but in different characters in it
yeah yeah I'm gonna be very English
student here but there's a word that I
know that's gonna come in useful this
issue uh top trick which essentially
means reflective surfaces but yeah we
are going to be using warning to
listeners we're going to be using the
words reflection symmetry mirror pretty
constantly so and yet Chuckster pose
just suppose I'll be in this glory the
glory word yeah and I don't mean to be
getting meta definition so early on but
the arse does it kind of look like the
bower up resume logo yeah do you think
that's where they got the idea from your
podcast from a 2015 podcast yeah and
again what I like about Watchmen is it
can be so verbose it can be so packed it
can often just be quite wordless and
quite wonderful and I love the fact we
have the light blinking in and off on
this first page and it's coloring each
panels of its switching on switching off
yeah oh it's just great like you know
adds such a that the colors mixing
together the the reds are so vibrant
it almost washes the panel out and then
it's sucked away in it really you know
red is the color of danger and it just
adds like panic to this first page even
though there's not much going on the
coloring really helps it stand out and
be vivid all it is is a guy walking down
the street but it still got such a life
to this first page and it just works
brilliantly it does yeah we see the
Ganga diner as well which is of course a
diner that the feature in this episode
as well probably probably more than most
ages I didn't realise just to go back to
the cover on the bottom Roy I literally
just saw that now you can see the the
box the Ganga diner box which is kind of
hidden on the curve of the page but yet
there's not really much going on in this
we see on the newspaper
Russia is invaded Afghanistan which is a
consequence of doctrine and going to
Mars in the previous issue
that has taken no time there and then
then we get into the the house itself
and again more is playing with these
concepts so smartly I love the fact that
Moloch is established in the story is
back in the day I could the crimebusters
Minutemen whatever day as being quite
the arch-nemesis of being quite a
vicious character but here he's just a
sort of lonely old man that's scared of
noises in the dark yet he's sort of been
reduced from a super villain to almost
this victim Rorschach really plays with
him basically what happens and this
meeting is Rorschach leaves a nut makes
a noise Moloch goes down with a gun to
investigate and he finds a note in the
fridge that says behind you and Roy X
just standing there behind him and it's
he's just playing with them this entire
section and it really sort of you know
Watchmen is about the deconstruction of
comic book characters and this is
probably the standout moment that just
shows like you know don't become a super
hero or a super villain because you're
not gonna have this life of grandeur for
very long and you're gonna have to go
back to normality and whatever you
influence it and Karma's gonna be
something where whoever you wrong it's
gonna come back to you like it would be
great a kind of see Lex Luthor in this
situation right he's old and gray and
you know he's scared of everything and
what are the the super humans of the day
just shows up in murder ISM yeah it's
just it's it's really just a great
concept that hadn't been done before
yeah yeah yeah and it just it takes its
time we you know we get essentially free
pages before Rorschach enters before we
get the title we just see Moloch walking
down the stairs now he's going further
down the stairs now he's looking down
the corridor and he just it builds and
builds we see the Gordian knot company
which you know he's obviously
established very well in this world we
see a little bit of Rorschach's jacket
coming out from the fridge here and and
yeah him playing with him him toying
with him it's kind of like I guess Ross
to a certain said he always wanted to be
this vigilante and he's getting to live
it out a little bit here in this
domestic saying yeah well this issue
pretty much is about Rorschach living
the life of a vigilante and you do get a
first-person perspective of him going
through the streets and you can see from
his perspective how importantly he takes
everything even though there's a bit of
buffoonery to it which sort of to me
symbolizes the way that as comic book
readers we take it so seriously and it's
only really within the past ten or
fifteen years that the the mass
population has started to take comic
books as seriously due to it being so
popular in the movies but I mean these
are really like these were really
serious things to us and people just
laughed like oh you read comics
that's crap primer that's the voice they
all had yeah yeah and yeah and maybe
Rorschach sort of symbolizes the the
modern person just looking at these
archetypes and these archaic figures of
villainy that well ones look like alive
on comic book pages and just breaking
them down to what they are like sad
pathetic things and encapsulating that
you know a lot of su pair of super
villains in the past even the future
have cheesy lines and kind of you know
lines that make you groan such as when
he but it's got a violent way he's
gripping this old man who's terrified
shoving him into this freezer and saying
you should cool down yeah yeah it's
great I think it's mainly the tone -
it's not yet levered as a punchline no I
am it's just really horrifying to see
you like cracking raw eggs and drink
laughs he taught us this man there's
just like a very sinister weird thing to
this like it's not it's not used for
jokes it's not used for a laugh hmm
another thing that sort of I think is
really well done is this issue sort of
recaps the plot points up to this
there's not um you wash out sort of
mentions things that have happened - to
really get answers out of Moloch
and it but it's not done in a sort of
you know previously on I mean a lot of
comics are re I was reading and forever
evil today which is a big massive tie-in
um crossover event within the new 52 and
there's literally like four pages where
they just have flashbacks yeah of what's
happened in the story so far so that new
readers can get to grips with it whereas
this delivers the same amount of
information but it's it's not done as
heavy exposition it's sort of
conversational and it works really well
it's not cliche and I think it's really
well done in that you know stuff like
this is underappreciated but it doesn't
make the work corny mm-hmm it really
develops it instead of just being like
oh here's a recap of something so you
don't forget yeah yeah he speaks about
the cancer list which helps you sort of
get back into the you know the grip of
it and just on a sort of symmetrical
note as well the story obviously takes
starts in Moloch's apartment ends in
Monica's apartment but if you look at
the page 20 24 & 25 which are mirroring
page 4 & 5 you have the long band across
the top you know on the other page and
on the on the on this one it's Moloch
not quite you know obviously aware
someone's there but not sure who it is
and then on page 25 it's the police
outside and it's just it's so rich isn't
it we don't have to point out every
single reflection but every time I read
this I'm just like I just like bloody
Elmore good on ya yeah well done maybe I
just like he dished did a finding
replace on his work yeah and you just
changed the pronouns on it yeah you know
I call that control F I imagine a lot
more types on one of those you know it's
old computer like dream and be like like
on the boss or some [ __ ] maybe on a
quill I don't know but yeah I mean yeah
he's here he's talking about the kind of
going for T he's pushing him into this
freezer which is which is pretty pretty
unseemly here and yeah it just doesn't
really get much done really makes
another sort of cheesy joke can't make
an omelet without breaking lay eggs of
course and then we go back into his
diary which
we said before in much more poetic voice
isn't it than him normally yeah he's not
as broken when he's written it down
they're writing something down in the
use of words like by whom mm-hmm which
year to Rorschach I don't think would
ever say that in conversation so yeah
it's a you know deep down with him
there's still this sort of real person
exists in there it's just completely
overshadowed by the the Vigilant each
self and he's very he's just been very
monomaniacal he's on his path he's and
there's certain things that aren't
playing for me he's a quite a pragmatic
guy he talks about comedian referring to
the island with artists and writers and
how you know this doesn't make any sense
to him and he you know waiting for a
flash of enlightenment in all this blood
and thunder and as ever with more one
thing his reference which goes into the
other so well and I love how he says
flash of enlightenment and then we cut
to the bada poster with the cops yeah
yeah and it sort of it's I think
Rorschach's biggest problem is the this
entire scenario is bigger than him and
he gets in too deep and it costs him his
life and yeah he's sort of he's very
low-level enforcer Rorschach and he just
gets so wrapped up in this thing that
questions morality and spiritualism and
it's it's just you get in way over his
head and eventually this is what kills
him and but he's too stubborn to turn
back we saw what do you kind of take
from the butter IIIi don't know I
suppose you know butter in this world
doesn't really mean anything because dr.
Manhattan you know exists in the in this
sphere I'm sure there's some sort of
theological juxtaposition there's the
word that you could sort of take sort of
what what is it they believe like
suffering is existence and all that sort
of suffer but for me what I see it's
less about the butter it's more just
about the microcosm of what's happened
here so what it seems like a guy has
murdered a child
yeah because of worry
about war and it's just a teaser isn't
it of cuz obviously dr. Manhattan has
caused this war inadvertently and it's a
teaser of what's gonna happen globally
because of doctor manette well because
of Ozzie man dies as well but because of
the whole the wrangling between the two
yeah and I think it's nice how the
butters in a triangle hmm which sort of
might symbolize awesome and Isis pyramid
yeah and where this is God that exists
within this pyramid sort of looking over
everything and what's the chaos goes and
around it I mean and and the blood
splattered on the Buddha which is very
similar to the one on the button yeah
yeah that's true I've never even noticed
that yeah the on the Buddha post it was
it being splashing blood I mean it's
crazy isn't it why would I I know is
that yesterday and I've been reading
this book for like ten years it's mad
there's so many details yeah and
probably you'll probably never take it
all in there be honest I will obviously
be there's so much stuff here that in
this kind of if you look on the next
page there's a purple triangle in the
circle on the wall and with a splash of
oil going like yellow splash of oil and
it just realized now that sort of
reflects the the butter yeah in in the
layout where there's a triangle there
and it's got a splash across it and it's
nice that thematically was sort of
saying all of these events tied together
and they will eventually all mean
something as a collective you're just
not understanding the big picture quite
yet mmm-hmm and there is also a there's
a grateful this is interesting that I
only learnt this via reading about this
ayah denied it there's a Grateful Dead
poster in the background and that is the
poster for an album which is called a
aox om o x0 a which is a palindrome a
mirror image in of itself as well so
it's just you know reinforcing the
primary theme of the issue and again
it's the details that Dave
Vern's puts the page in the little bear
that soaked in blood on the floor and
you see the kid the kids foot and his
Snoopy shoes is so sad yeah it's really
horrific and it's not like a glamorous
crime scene it's it's a realistic one
and often these don't get picked I mean
today they do but back then these this
level of debauchery didn't get depicted
in comic books and he just had like the
the comics cold seal of approval yeah
and which limited a lot of violence that
could be shown in comic books and this
is kind of just above and beyond that
and it almost revolutionizes it for what
could be shown in comics yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's uh it's a pretty watershed
moment and these cops
I always forget their names but they you
know they're quite important in the
story they kind of come in and out you
know they have they have a lot of
relevance another thing that comes in
and out the story deaf I know you're not
the biggest fan we get a lot of black
freighter in this issue
yeah I think that's why I didn't really
like this issue that much right I do
like the little guy who sits and reads a
comedy goes shi-it yeah I like that
right but the black freighter itself and
I didn't really yeah don't really I mean
there's a nice little panel here where
the guy on the black freighter you start
eating this he catches a seagull out in
there and then just eat it raw yeah yeah
and then on the next page
you've got Dan talking them through a
chicken leg it's a it's the same image
pretty much again with the mirror in but
you know the the black freighter itself
yeah yeah it's a it's a little bit
overkill and I think in this issue I
think there's an issue later on as well
that also has it predominantly in there
and it just sometimes it's just I think
want to reread it doesn't age as well to
me but I know that's not a point it's
kind of because the whole you know it's
the realism of this world and so before
you know comics we superheroes don't
exist it's pirates and you know this is
this world but III like it from a sort
of technical standpoint obviously more
can inhabit
hundreds of voices so convincingly and
it's great
two-seam in this as well and of Justices
straight-up horror comic but yeah I
agree all I'm really taking when this
section is easy to see goal which is
pretty grotesque and awesome yeah
to me it's just not necessary to the
plot which is why a kind of dog gel with
hip how much
yeah I'm not invested in that character
at all like I've never ever read this
and been invested in the black Freya
because it just sort of getting in the
way a bit to me yeah yeah and I just
wanted there's been times when I've read
Watchmen out just skipped it completely
hmm yeah just like the back issues you
you know like under the hood yeah and I
just feel like it's superfluous mm-hmm
it adds it's supplementary material but
it's not necessary no you can skip under
the hood quite easily whereas this ties
into the plot and it sometimes
overbearing yeah yeah yes to panel and I
mean we'll get to the you know the
PostScript which is all black freighter
as well yeah which I remember I remember
reading that when I was younger like
really struggling with that like really
not getting it and like you know it's a
bit clearer in Outlook I read it this
morning or what we'll get to there's
only one thing I think you need to take
away from that I mean little things on
these pages I really like the kid where
he's showing the comic to the to the
audience at the bottom of page a and
it's basically you're seeing what's on
the next page we're just kind of you
know you move for and also I love that I
love that panel of the the black
freighter on the waves and just the
waves are taken at the majority of it I
think it's really well drawn yeah that's
really nice and you know if this was a
standalone thing I'd probably enjoy a
lot more but it's the fact that I'm
having to wade through it to get to what
I want to read yeah that it's more of an
annoyance and it's its style of a
substance to me which you know it
fearful similar you could kind of say
that about this issue itself
sure well you know it's it's great that
everything there is you know is a bit of
style over substance it's not it you
know doesn't massively play into the
plot it's just the fact that more I
wanted to do an issue that reflect
itself so we did it it's not it's not
essential that heat had to do that style
but it's amazing I pulled it off I'm not
I'm not discrediting now yeah but like
the black fryer you know it's it's not
necessary yeah yeah yeah and you know
here we have done it all and subscribed
yet don't ya yeah I mean we love this
issue I should say I'm gonna take what
you're saying I think I think I've read
somewhere recently watching has like a
crystal like structure where everything
reflects everything so I guess it makes
sense that you know issue five
essentially I guess a few sixes but
essentially the middle of the story if
you're being technical has the mirror in
the know Mabel going too far yet let's
get back to Laurie and Dan and oh my god
there's another mirror which we have Dan
looking back but actually kind of
looking forward into the mirror I really
like that player does with your mind
yeah it's just really they kind of tell
what's going on yeah I used to work in a
bar where it was sort of like a 360 bar
so you could walk the bar was basically
in the center and there was a mirror in
between the two sides and people would
stand and think they were looking
through the other side even though their
reflection was there you know it was
dead weird like mirrors often playing
with people and they can massively trick
you they still get animals all the time
oh yeah and it's nice that this issue is
chocka chocka blocka with mirrors it is
and I mean you know here we have Basie
dan has ever infatuated with Laurie
we've learned that she's been cut off
because obviously Doc's my hands cough
the world so why would the government
need Laurie you know in any way she's
useless to them really and she probably
wasn't much used to begin with you know
he's asking her to come back and yet
again but her friends own Frediani yeah
yes it's been like he's been waiting for
this he's like one of them lads on
Facebook whenever a girl like splits up
with her boyfriend and she puts some
stats like feeling so down at the moment
and some guy friends on Freddy I call
them her he always writes like I'm here
if you want to chat babe you know
I mean yes yeah yeah and you know I
guess I guess you know we've established
that these people they prefer their
lives as super beings to a certain
extent so the mirror again
you know you so many so many mirror
metaphors we go back into Rorschach's
Journal
with the next slot I like that we see
inside his flatten we see the Heinz
beans it's no surprise that he lives a
slob I guess yeah it just doesn't care
like bang hello
yeah all he cares about is being a
vigilante mmm and that's it he hasn't
got any he hasn't got the personality
way can have friends where he could have
a butler
Leo tied you know he's just he's a
complete slob and this homeless thing is
just a cover he doesn't want anyone to
pay attention to him which you know
picking homeless people that's probably
quite a good idea because how many times
Tom I know you're a bit tight with your
money right right how many times a day
do you walk past a homeless man and like
look look the other way inked up and
goes have you got any money go
I've got no change you've got you want
to be away from him as quickly as
possible don't you Tom I know yeah
you've never bought a big issue in your
life who you trying to I've got a lot of
big issues emotionally so yeah yeah yeah
so it's quite a good disguise do it in
John wick to where there's a huge
assassin community that is just homeless
people and because they can kind of get
about the city unnoticed no one really
pays attention of them and no one wants
to spend time talking to them so
Rorschach's or distance himself from all
no social aspects of his life to focus
on his mission Bruce Wayne sort of does
that as well but not in this scale and
he purposely like ruins relationships
just because he knows that they're going
to get in the way of crime-fighting yeah
so it's nice that Moore's taking this a
step above that and instead of being
like a reclusive socialite he's made
them just a homeless person
and you know Rorschach is basically you
know trailing them to a certain extent
it's quite cool that we see when they're
leaving the diner we get the journal
then we see pretty much the moment they
leave is kind of put into here as war
shacks watching you know he's told
Moloch you know where to reach him in
the trash can as well yes just some of
the writing I really like the see is an
animal fierce and complicated to
understand it I read its droppings its
sense the movements of its parasites so
you know again he's such a prosaic great
writer but doesn't learn I think you
know again there's bigger pictures in
play here such as such as Adrian I mean
we get a little bit of black freighter
stuff before as well but again it's just
lots of really you know lovely illusions
as opposed to plot plot and now yeah you
know we get into Adrian which I mean
he's he's the kind of a bit of a mystery
man early on in the series isn't he you
don't really get much of him I guess
until this point really exclusive scenes
yeah and he sort of juxtaposes
Rorschach's homelessness because his
grand lifestyle like Rorschach will go
through the bin you know I mean like I
guess come neon this person right right
I don't I don't think any homeless
people listen here this but the first I
don't think anyone isn't Stu this
podcasts era Eric does thank you Eric
look pretty safe thanks Eric no I'm only
kidding about homeless people yeah don't
unsubscribe do not on the subscribe I'll
kill myself but Adria
Rorschach's communicating through going
through the trash can whereas Adrian
he's meeting were like journalists and
stuff and he's got a fancy secretary and
he's got three no he's got four
escalators in his Lobby yeah you know I
mean he doesn't have the one escalator
he got four it's that busy the young
it's full yeah yeah yeah it's you know
yet again we have the surface of his
desk we have the you know the the V we
have where the I guess she had the
secretary the the the associate I like
how she's talking about the toy line as
well that's very wink wink on Alan
Moore's Park yeah they can't do any
supervillain toys because all the
supervillains are dead yeah it's like
what what does that matter but I guess
it's kind of black humor isn't it yeah
but
nice that the Adrienne's desk shines so
brightly that it's got a reflection in
it as well yes yeah yeah definitely
indeed the entire Palace is so shiny
like the floors reflect everything
reflects he's like one big walk in
fearful symmetry issue five comic and
it's um you can see on me I've just
found it now I think it's on issue ten
the sort of post route you can other if
you remember you can see some of the
toys and you can even actually get an
owl ship as an accessory which I'd love
yeah it's a shame that DC would up for
merchandise as they are today where they
literally make it time for everything
yeah yeah cuz there would be so in these
well there may be baby pop vinyls
wouldn't they these days yeah don'ts
like them off I've got about 40 M night
I know you do started collecting them
last year and I'm addicted of them I've
just spent four equal on one which one
it was a Batman Joker Suicide Squad one
okay
holy did it in America yeah there was
only about two thousand of them don't
slice off yeah it'll be worth something
one day would you mean it won't be worth
and doesn't subscribe so as a good time
to mention my patreon his name yeah all
mad they so dizzy unless you're homeless
you don't need to donate to the patreon
then but but but yeah we get to see
inside I mean it just he's kind of you
know he's lobby of his of his Trump
Tower as it were like you know it's kind
of crazy to see in this they're sort of
talking about you know nothing really
like you know she talks about the day
core being obsessed with Egyptian stuff
and a morbid death and then the gunman
comes in points the gun and you know
Adrian he's nonplussed isn't he
obviously we know that he's expecting it
but he's so calm
yeah well it's sort of I see the
secretary and the fact that she's
talking about how she isn't worried
about death
then gets murdered seconds like it sort
of speaks to the ignorance of the people
of the world they're on the brink of war
and other than the vigilant is very few
seem to be interested at all like these
people don't realize that they're very
close to getting killed and you know as
human dies this might be like his moment
where he realizes yeah
I'm definitely going through with a plan
because people just don't get it they do
not get how closed or a death and it
could happen any second and you know
Annie Annie a murder them all mhm mhm
and yeah it's just it's kind of its kind
of really sad I mean obviously I guess
her last words are Oh God look out he's
but she's like I mean losing 10 pounds
that's a coming for my next raises are
coming for and we get to just lost 21
years is that the soul it's 21 grams now
that's a heavy souls yeah you know maybe
she meant Punk like 10 pounds as in yeah
like money yeah because pound in
England's like money crazy [ __ ] yeah
whatever and he shot her and then robbed
her the gun the gun is pulled and then
we get to you know one of the most
memorable panels in the entirety of
watching an awesome awesome panel where
we're getting a mirror of course of of
the book as well with the V I just love
this second yeah when it pulls out one
of the things that actually feels like
this is the center of the book doesn't
yeah yeah it's not because it's 12
issues long and this is only issue 5 but
yeah it feels like it's assess
spiritually yeah yeah it does and um I
love how you know we've been told that
the day calls all very Egyptian and
really honest on page 13 I can't really
see anything that would make me think
that but obviously in this issue we're
you know Ozymandias is kind of you know
while he's secretary shot and then he
defends itself you see the Egyptian head
in in the bath and stuff and I was
reading online about this I never
considered this but it is quite true
another sort of symmetry is the guy's
face being smashed into the face of the
Pharaoh
okay yeah so it's not perfect and he
does kind of look like it kind of looks
like Rorschach I don't think that's
intentional but it colors like cleaned
up Rorschach
yeah well it's sort of like might be
referencing awesome and Isis idea of the
Egyptian pharaohs meeting modern man mmm
in there being blood mmm because of it
maybe I'm reading a bit too much in her
there yeah I don't quite know what you
mean but though I agree that yeah and
immediately all these ideas of the past
mean the ideas of the present really
yeah it's just causing blood regardless
of any symbolism always badass that he'd
reflect that he sort of bounces off the
bullet with that thing yeah and I loved
the way that when this guy chokes on the
suicide pill it works both ways the
first time you read it and if you don't
know it was hemolysis the villain it
sort of looks like he's trying to save
them yet on this once you get hindsight
that it this is all a ruse you can see
it's like clean shoving the yeah it's
perfect you wouldn't question it if
you're even there in the moment it makes
sense and I love how I want to know
who's behind this he says and behind him
there's the V yeah yeah absolutely
again more doing brilliant work that
we're now [ __ ] all over
I thought terrible analysis and then he
says cool the toy people and cancel the
extension of the line as like a neat
yeah and I just realized looking at the
panel now the the what the dead woman is
just there her legs you know all we can
see is the legs in the blood yeah well
I'm not being funny tom but if you've
ever read a secretary CV right they're
not very hard to replace putting out Wow
Wow
okay you have a new one by next week on
the right way I don't want to slow do
you mean of what do you mean I've
slacked off on this people aren't saving
this issue don't unsubscribe please
don't unsubscribe and yeah so the way
I've sort of seen this section with
Ozymandias talking about the the
commodity and selling the action figures
and all the majors major films at
you know once a diamond is I think
Rorschach and well the entire all the
characters in this really symbolized
that you might be able to give up the
hero lifestyle but it never really goes
away and Dan still wants to do it so
expect us still wants to do it
dr. Manhattan still wants to do a
Rorschach still does it you know once
just because Ozymandias has become a
businessman he would still have this
yearning to tackle problems the fact
that all the major villains are dead now
really speaks to the fact he would look
for new problems to tackle which is wise
went to this massive problem of the wall
and it's he's just parading around us
this businessman he's he's got you know
he's Minds constantly working on how
he's going to save the world and the
fact that he's paid this guy to come in
and attempt to murder him it just shows
that everything's part of the plan for
him and he never stopped being a super
hero
mmm yeah as as the newspaper guy says
you know he's a real hero did charity
work revealed his name like he had
nothing to hide you know the perfect
disguise really in plain sight yeah so
so much juxtaposition of course this
issue is flooded with it you know you
never know what's bearing down on you he
says in the black freighter my raft
beneath my raft something moves I mean
all we can see is in the service and I
quite like this section in the black
freighter where he see he thinks it's
boats but it's actually sharks bearing
down and it's so gruesome that the raft
is less made up of like him and corpses
and they're just kind of pursuing him
for the flesh yeah it's weird I've never
quite got what this symbolizes like yeah
is it just a guy going crazy who he's
realizing he's gonna have to destroy the
world to you know get get Eric on the
line get Eric to tell us what it means
because I know it ties in that was human
diets but I'm not quite sure exactly
what yeah yeah sort of on the body of
corpses
I guess throughout the sort of the the
genocide the II but I know I know what
you're saying yeah there's not a
clear-cut
and yet email in I mean Eric or
otherwise emails in watching a watchman
pod at gist Eric yet or just Eric just
anyone else at email saying we're not
gonna I'm not gonna read it I'm not
reading I'm not having to emails right
over week too many well if it's from a
homeless secretary okay she will be
homeless cuz that easier replace wait
its watch me bad day yeah yeah what do
you mean you put were tax return in the
shredder euro that's all it takes and
yeah we get you know this is a Rorschach
issue as you said earlier we get a lot
of his his journal here as well kind of
just building out how depraved you know
the world that he lives within how sort
of terrifying is to a certain extent and
you know I love how a lot of a lot of
superheroes they get changed in in phone
booths but watch there but Rorschach
there in dustbin cans yeah it's a really
good like part it's rather you see
something like this in it in the comic
where you're seeing through the eyes of
the the person walking along the street
getting changed and then approaching
someone to take them down
he loves it when he sees this guy trying
to rape the woman he's like the nine the
nights being generous to me he has
something rewarding in his eyes like
he's obviously getting off on the fear
and it's just a very strange that like
anyone else in that situation would be
crapping themselves like you walking
along a dark alley you see a man
attacking a woman you know most people
would run the other way mm-hm and the
fact that were all shacks like over the
movie the night's been generous and the
way the you know the the rapist and the
victim looks similar to the Hiroshima's
stencil on the top left of the page as
well that you know again you know of
course there's nothing that's game
Passmore and we get the letter from from
not from Moloch from from Jacobi you
know as heylia's here so that's a very
interesting obviously calls Damascus
face as well which you discussed in
previous episodes and we get back to the
friendzone and we get back to Laurie she
stopped there yeah totally stop that I
like how raw Chuck says that he gets rid
of his disguise yeah you ban there's
balance his disguise and he's putting on
his face like throughout this issue you
mentions how is he left his skin in the
dustbin
yeah and the guy's a psychopath isn't he
he doesn't see himself he saw of like
these new Jim Carrey in the views that
are emerging where he's talking about
how he's not anyone he's not him yeah
he's just you know I don't know what
he's talking about
no yeah he saw he doesn't have a self
anymore he's just became the symbol um
he's just inhabiting this body you know
some of this stuff to him Kerry says I
must admit does make sense hmm he just
says everything's happening which you
know Tyson had a lot of the stuff I
believe like I'll ask you a question
yeah Tom what's your next thought wow I
do you see what I'm saying
everything's just happening think
thinking just happens you can't plan it
thinking just happens everything just
happens anyway I say that in because I'm
out and carries a big listener and I
don't want Jim carry it and subscribe
please don't unsubscribe Jim Carrey know
he's doing up and subscribe and it's
pretty much actually man on the moon i
watch that recently and I guess that's
quite it I know it's Mars so it doesn't
quite work yeah they're releasing a
Netflix documentary about the behind the
scenes stuff of that where it talks
about Jim Carrey we've got so on a
character that he actually lost who Jim
Carrey was he was so used to being this
person that when he had to go back to
being Jim Carrey you couldn't be which
is why sort of ended up you know
patrolling alleyways at night put in
faith is like masks in bins and stuff
and attack and rapists wasn't with Jim
Carrey in
- he was he didn't like it though
said it was too violent yeah yeah I
remember watching at the cinema right I
didn't think it was as white as good as
the first one
no I wasn't anything special was it no
no no it wasn't very kick-ass there we
go there we go what I mean Mark Miller
is I I think ideas wise he's good but I
don't know well don't slug the light off
he didn't make the movie comic-book
writer he's not a filmmaker who do you
select the director of not the toilet it
was obviously good enough that they
thought let's make a movie of it gee
stop don't mock Miller do not
unsubscribe jeez mark I'm big fan of
your stories not so much your your write
it but yeah we you know we get to we get
to Laurie and we get quite a dare I say
risque like she's um I don't want to
sound creepy she's quite busty Laurie
yeah
just world she's like a normal woman
isn't she yeah yeah she's not nineties
x-men you know how they're all very
exaggerated physically yeah she bit of a
minger and she she's very nice and again
it's mirrors you know we have we mirror
camera so could play a drinking game how
many times have said mirrors yeah are
you dead within the first 10 minutes and
we see this and subscribe if you're not
oh my god we've got no subscribers left
now so there is and it's almost placed
like a eighties John Hughes thing
doesn't it like the Gorky nerd has the
choice to say something then goes back
to his bed and you know Rue's the day
yeah I could have made my move it's
there
Lolita spirit which means it's it's
called staircase where I've probably
butchered the the French pronunciation
there because I've never actually heard
it said I've just seen it written down
it basically means weight of the
staircase
and it means you know once some things
have we'll all do it
we'll have this big thing that were
build up to and it happens and then as
we're walking away we start thinking of
all the things we would have said if in
the perfect scenario and that sort of
Dan's life isn't it it's just constantly
like walking away from stuffing in our
crow I should I did this I'm such a
friendzone Freddie please don't
unsubscribe if your name's freddie and
you're in the friend zone you know Dan
talks of hell and damnation and then we
get back to you know you the Holy Light
clearly for you the black freighter
you know Hades is wet Hades is lonely
and just some some fantastic yeah yeah
me too I like sharks
yeah yeah yeah I think there's some
really beautifully pulpy writing so
basically the the sailors stamps you
know some sort of like carved javelin
into the shock and the shock repel so
he's saying half blind half dead holy
deranged by agony the yellow Leviathan
attempted to swim away dragging my raft
in its bloody wake i hung him
desperately cursing in the bitter
stinging spray
I know it's terrific writing that's up
to you great and the imagery is really
good in this as well I keep having this
like reoccurring dream not like every
night but like once every five months or
something where I'm swimming in the sea
a shark comes along and I've gotta like
kick it and get away and stuff right and
this brings back those happy memories
and you know you thought eventually the
shark died as well so it's just more
dense and I don't know if this is like
there will not be happy Peter please
yeah not subscribe and we we see you see
dr. Manhattan on the second panel of
page 21 which i think is probably the
first time if you see him in that in
this issue which is quite you know you
basically get you know him from from the
Nova Express which we ended no very
suppose the New Frontiers when all these
publication exists or in this world here
we get the taxi cabbie as well I think
she drove lorry from the base originally
I think they did and she's got a poster
with a try and go on ago yeah I don't
know what the symbolism for the poster
with a triangle and
but maybe it's just time this you know
these pyramids are everywhere Osman
diocese everywhere yeah yeah it is just
unbelievable the sort of omniscience
that he has here and yeah they gave
women against rape guar which is a guar
is actually a famous metal band as well
so I'm guessing that was a play on that
and yeah we get we get to see again the
I don't like gay women against rape know
they were doing it I've got no so I'm
getting me YouTube's getting shut down
someone's putting a bloody copyright
strike and not against me against you
your content teeth yes yes there's a as
a matter reference there and when when
she's looking at hustler in the middle
panel could you argue that the the
woman's legs is making a triangle yeah
you know this is another reach when the
guys riding on top of the shark will see
it from a front view and where he sit on
the raft in the Black Friday sort of
looks like a triangle you know it looks
like a triangle those jaws in that mouth
right look at the poster it's got this
jagged jaws and the same all around
there it's that more is killing it more
is absolutely smashing it with this I've
literally got goosebumps now I've never
noticed that crazy me neither
because I was always looking at that
poster thing and why is that jagged like
mouth circle thing on him and then more
so that hopefully he's been looking
you're not paying attention it's like
it's almost a cliche to say about books
and films all you always know is
something new but watch when you could
you always do yeah you always do it's
like it's unbelievable and then we get
back you know to the guys to the cops to
this the guy with the bald head that of
course remember from the first page of
Watchmen you know you sort of going
above him and the Ganga diner is
watching that that blimp fly by which
we'd seen underneath
just it builds such afridi world of the
sea you know so so well and I love I
love how his Rorschach as raw shark I
mean that's genius
yeah Rorschach which ties into the black
bloody fray it's nice that these feel
like a reference and you know they get
the call off they've got the bastards
head in a play and we get back to where
we started back outside molix apartment
you know Rorschach is back in the in his
donned the lock seemingly has been
repaired again like Gordian knot Rocha
keeps me business I reckon I think he
does the lads doing a good job here he
probably has shares in them that's how
he's able to keep like Easy's wealth of
he's covered stocked with baked beans
and stuff hmm
and I mean bollocks dead you know bullet
to the head and I I wonder if there's a
little bit of emotion not necessarily at
this moment of washout but you know
pursuing a villain over so many years
and then for them finally to be dead
it's you can tell he shops you can you
know you can see the ink on his face
yeah it's it's weird seeing him this
vulnerable it's sort of you know this
ends on Rorschach getting unmasked and
it's kind of its really anticlimactic
like I always sort of envisioned
superheroes as a certain way like
Superman he's a reporter he's just he's
in he's there he's just on the verge of
telling Lois Lane that he loves her
spider-man he's this is like what a view
spider-man is he's just graduated high
school he loves Mary Jane but he hasn't
told her he makes money selling photos
and he he's a month behind on his rent
at all times Rorschach you know he's
this weird guy in a detective Cole kind
of prowls the night and and then when
you get the unmasking you just think ah
is that is that all he is it's a shame
and but what's great is this guy he's
appeared so
much in the book when you see the math
like and with his mask off and you never
want to know ystem is basically the guy
who walks around holding that end is
nigh sign and and he's quite memorable
but you would never pick him as
Rorschach and so it does show that the
disguise works really well and but it
also could makes you think oh no this
hero that seems so cool in the first
couple of issues he was shooting
grappling hoops of buildings you know I
mean he was sneaking into like and
there's the CIA and you know he was he
was great and now he's been reduced to
just this homeless guy eats cold baked
beans is a ginger - the great one for
ginger right now please do subscribe for
ginger it's really just sad it's like
never meet heroes because this is what
happens and they say like he stinks I'm
jumping ahead a bit here but yeah he's
just he's the lads the letdown he wears
shoes that make him look taller and it's
just like gee it's a winning me Oh Jay
Simpson in 1992 you like juice you're
the best and his wife allegedly and am i
right well Richard Lee I don't think
yeah yeah I'm sure I'm sure there's a no
j oj podcast out there but you know i
mean what we learn ultimately though for
all his flaws he's resourceful as [ __ ]
you know he is outnumbered with guns
with the police with professionals you
know 20 to 1 but he still stands his god
and yet again Oh badass line doesn't he
cuz they go Rorschach or coming in at 10
seconds I hope you're ready just like
when you are mmm it reminds us a bit of
this Batman this Justice League story
that Grant Morrison did basically these
these super-powered lads that come down
at Earth
they'll wad doing everything in the way
the Justice League Batman come along
helping the Justice League in these
batwing you know the lad though he
crushed it they're all like ah the goal
of Justice League they were like should
we get Batman they're like nah thought
that laddie so he's only a human sod the
lad don't unsubscribe if you're human
anyway Batman you know he shows up later
he's he's like years or is all right
lads I've come to rescue the Justice
League they're like what a mug you are
we're gonna knock you out
um anyway goes look yeah I've realized
you're white Martians white Martians
yeah there are they're allergic to fire
they can shape-shift that's how new no
one knew anyway
Batman's only buddy filled the room with
gasoline has knee and he just gets a
match out he's like ready when you are
you know I'm saying reminds us of that a
bit Grant Morrison probably nicked it
from this we probably nicked a lot of
stuff from Alan Moore but don't want to
get I mean I need to read that I've
heard and grab Watson yeah it's actually
done better than this moment it's just
nice to see like these super-powered
villains being like we're gonna kick the
crap out you about mine you say Grady
way yeah and I love this section I've in
the sections [ __ ] awesome I think it
just it's tense I love how you see him
like the match in the doorway as they're
going in they're scared he uses the
pepper I think the art works brilliant I
think the flames on the stairway look
look fantastic
right you know they nearly tear apart
the place as well and you know arguably
he has one real weapon weapon which is a
grappling hook and take down most men
and kind of he does all he can do you
know he jumps out the window there but
ultimately you know if you're
outnumbered you're outnumbered you know
and he does get rapped which is just
it's kind of its kind of almost with the
thing with the super isn't it it's like
there is you know there are laws through
our civilization and you can't act
without it to a certain extent but
ultimately
there's gonna be more of them than you
so you can't really win yeah he didn't
learn kung-fu this night did he
he saw I've been going around hitting
people like aerosol cans on fire and
stuff you know when that used to do when
you were like 13 and you realized that
deodorant you could set a light and sway
that people so yeah in a situation like
this he's not got the resources that you
know someone like Batman would have he
doesn't have like a Batmobile or similar
he can fly away and I've just got that
there panel up from before he does say
ready when you are so he is there he is
you know Grant Morrison maybe was
reference in drying the very interesting
yeah maybe yeah yeah so but you know
Batman kicks the crap out of them where
is Rorschach
gets the crap kicked over him yeah and
again we have the light flashing on and
off as we had before we see that we see
Walsh activate his hat as well first of
all as he learned so which you know
makes him look well studies for the
uglier than he was for that the mask
being pulled off and his mouth blooded
is being wrenched off him finally his
demonic visage and the final line
everything balances he's just the
perfect end isn't it because this is so
about the yin and the yang yeah and he
just says everything but and says the
signal cut there Tom said I don't know
if you've just said that yourself right
right but yeah and everything balances
yeah I was just saying the yin and the
yang and again we end on you know the
light and all of the thing and he's
taken in and it's a great ending really
yeah it sort of reminds me of The
Killing Joke and which cuts to a puddle
and it's all this somber moment and
where are you just looking at bottle in
the rain and it's just like yeah
everything's over yeah so yeah I mean
you know that wraps it up it's not as
perhaps his action-packed no ends strong
I think and I think you know from a
structural point it is a marvel and it
progresses us well and then then we end
we
not that interesting kind of end here
it's quite dense about you know the sort
of the the treasure Treasure Island
Treasury of comics and kind of a look
back and Joe Orlando is real I should
say there's a real person which is nice
that they're playing in in here but
really the only thing you need to know
from this section dear listeners is the
Mack che what wrote the script and he's
one of the people on the island who kind
of configure thing else that's about it
I think this sort of tells the story of
comics itself the started off camp they
got great yeah I had to reflect the
decay in the world and that's about it
so yeah it sort of informs you that when
people first started writing comics
there were nice and friendly and even
get like a sample page from one of the
older ones and then it talks about how
this sort of as the world got more
informed on all the evils of it the work
reflected that and you know the story we
essentially see for our watchman is
marooned and I like how they talk about
towards the end of his writing career
che began his controversial run of
issues based on the contents of
plundered books in the library of the
freighters captain including banned
tomes supposedly originally headed for
eternal suppression when the vaults of
that can see the scribe is blatantly
pornographic four of the projected
stories were rejected by DC so I like
that you know it goes further and
further and further and you know I mean
more himself and makes you read Lost
Girls but I know it that is porn you
know he said himself trying to rescue
porn as a means of of narrative as
opposed to just you know I've actually
got it but I haven't read it yeah I
flicked through it and it made me feel
uncomfortable it's quite it seems almost
Peter Philly I know it's not but it's
kind of you know very young girls in
those sort of positions yes just I've
got basically got this massive Alan
Moore collection book and I know that's
then output I just don't want to read
ably others
i watch porn you know what i mean it's
on me falls you know it's it's in the
airwaves yeah well um it's in your
imagination
yeah every second of the day well um you
know we'll be back next week for the
abyss gazes be back there that's a quote
from a movie they're in it yeah yeah I
think diehard I think but uh you know
the next is Rorschach's origins which i
think is a fantastic episode especially
the mind games that he plays with the
therapist you know I love that sort of
stuff any any any closing thoughts on
fearful symmetry death yeah
two mirrors that face each other
reflect forever Jesus that's profound
that's profound all uh you know I'll
leave I'll leave our listeners to dwell
on that please comment below please send
us emails watching a watchman potty
humor calm yeah please subscribe as well
check out deaths patreon check out
battle rap resume which has a kind of
mirrored logo my other podcast my battle
round yeah if Justice League comes out
next Friday yeah yeah so I've already
done most the video I'm ranking all of
the Batman movies from best to worst
yeah and I'm gonna see where Justice
League sits in that and then I'm gonna
drop the video so make sure you're on my
channel just hit f5 from about Friday
onward all right all right well death as
always it's been an answered tree thank
you so much ma'am thank you and thank
you listening and that's a good night
from me
it's a good night from Qui and let ya
alright later their favor listen guys
[Music]